my brother robert baratheon had raised
the banners of
storm's end our ancestral castle
against the mad king aerys john aaron of
the vale
an eddard stark of the north stood with
him and hoster tully of the riverlands
would join
but their lands were far from ours and
separated by the combined strength of
the west
the reach and king's landing itself
even robert's own lords were against him
it was the hardest choice i've ever made
my brother or my king blood or honor
ares ruled by right of all the laws in
westeros
everyone knew the price of defiance
but there are deeper older laws
the younger brother bows before the
elder
i followed robert early in the war
mace tyrell's indecisive victory at
ashford
cut robert off from storm's end instead
of pursuing robert
and risking his record mace tyrell
turned east
and laid siege to our home his vast army
and navy encircled us and prevented any
resupply by land or sea
if a wagon tried to reach us it was
burnt if the ship tried to land it was
sunk
we were locked in storm's end to starve
but robert commanded me to hold the
castle no matter the cost
he could ill afford to lose his ancient
seat which had never fallen
while robert smashed rhaegar on the
trident
my men ate the dogs because the horses
had already been devoured
while the lannisters sacked king's
landing
we ate the rats if the smuggler davos
had not slipped through the terrell
blockade with his onions
we'd have eaten our own dead but i held
the castle
until lord eddard remembered us and
marched to lift the siege
the tyrells didn't even put up a fight
and robert threw a feast to celebrate
lord eddard's victory
i was sent to the royal island
stronghold of dragonstone to deal with
viserys and daenerys
the last surviving targaryen children
before i arrived however they escaped
across the narrow sea
robert was furious he stripped me of
storm's end
and gave it to that prancing fool renly
my younger brother wars are not as good
for smugglers as you'd think
every harbour filled with guards and
inspectors
and the seas filled with blockades and
pirates paid by each side to prey on the
other
though i had no love for the mad king
i'd grown up around the power of king's
landing
i figured this robert baratheon would
end the same as the other rebel lords
burnt to ash but he didn't
the north the riverlands and the veil
joined him
and then the taverns people drank the
robert's health openly
brave fools i thought but i had a family
who'd be left in the cold if i lost my
head
when mess tyrell marched on robert's
home of storm's end
i spared the end of the rebellion the
castle was garrisoned by
robert's younger brother stannis and the
small guard and would not hold out for
long
when it fell robert would be homeless
and his support would bleed away
this i knew from experience months later
stannis was still holding the castle
nobody cared
but on voyages i had seen what famine
does
and i thought of all those men in
storm's end who would die
unmourned and forgotten no better
than flea bottom orphans i told my wife
and myself that i'd get a high price for
the onions and salt beef
in truth i knew i'd be captured by the
tyrell galleys are drowned
but i was too stubborn later that night
in the dark
in a tiny boat with a black sail i
cursed myself
and the moonlight as i waited for the
tide to turn when it did
the wind beat the sail so hard i ripped
it down fearing the terrell ships would
hear
luckily they had grown lacks with
muffled oars
alone i steered my cargo through the
treacherous currents and snarls of rock
that gave shipbreaker bay its name
the waves finally carried me soaked and
near blind from sea water
through the mouth of the cavern beneath
the castle
then stannis baratheon arrived
the siege had left him gaunt but not
weak never weak
he greeted me and accepted my onions
with cool courtesy betraying no emotion
even as all wept
he told out the food to his wife and
each of his men before he ate himself
a portion no larger than any other
when he finally thanked me i could see
his mind had already returned to the
castle's defense
his duty after aries fell and lord stark
lifted the siege
stunner summoned me for my salvation of
storm's end
i was to be granted a knighthood a keep
of my own
and my son taken into stannis's personal
service
davos of flea bottom had become sir
davis of house seaworth
and his son would serve the king's own
brother
but for my previous crimes as a smuggler
i was to have the fingertips of one hand
taken off above the highest joint
stannis held that i had flouted the laws
of the land for years
and a good act does not wash out the bad
in one fell swoop
or five stannis gave my son a future and
my family a name
that i could never have imagined nor
earned on my own
i still keep the finger bones in a bag
around my neck
to remind me what i was and what i owed
a stannis
for during my many years as a smuggler i
visited many ports
taverns and back alleys and saw many
things in this world
but never justice until stannis
rebellion the crimes of house targaryen
were too
heinous to go unanswered
the noble houses of baratheon stark and
aaron united to oppose and overthrow the
line of the cursed
dragon kings while ned stark and aaron
secured an alliance with the tullys of
riverrun
i called the banners of storm's end and
rode out in force against the mad
king and his minions gods those were
some
battles our first victory occurred at
summer hall where i faced off against an
army of dragon loyalists and won
three battles in a single day three in
one
day seven hells that was a glorious day
we tried to take ashford castle in the
reach but the tyrells beat us back
we had to regroup my army was pursued
north by eris's army
and took refuge in the stony sept in the
riverlands
when the targaryen army entered the town
the sept bells
told a signal to the townspeople of the
battle that was to come
as the targaryens searched from house to
house for me
the combined forces of ned stark and the
tullys swept into the city
gods what a day that was
it's now known as the battle of the
bells
we overwhelmed the mad king's forces and
sent them
scampering back to king's landing
aerys son rhaegar who started the whole
damn thing finally emerged from hiding
in the south
and assembled his own army to face us
as for the mad king he must have been
pissing himself
the battle that would decide the fate of
the seven kingdoms
occurred at the crossing of the green
fork of the trident river
rhaegar commanded the royal host which
was some forty thousand strong
my forces were outnumbered by nearly
five thousand
men but that didn't matter
they were fresh but we were
battle-hardened and had
justice on our side
as the battle raged around us i faced
off with rhaegar
the stag and the dragon right there in
the ford of the river
i fought with the fury of ten men
reigning blow after blow up on that
vile prince before burying my warhammer
in his
chest i hit him so hard the rubies on
his armor broke
free flinging them into the stream they
call it the ruby ford
now with that scum rhaegar dead
and the royal army shattered our next
move was to make for king's landing
but i'd sustained a few wounds in the
battle and was unable to ride
i sent ned stark to the capital to face
the mad
king and make him pay for his crimes
the targaryens blood of the dragon and
the last of old valyria were loved by
their subjects
and admired far and wide as the greatest
dynasty in the history of the western
world
but the peace and prosperity of nearly
three centuries of targaryen rule
was shattered by the usurper robert
baratheon
and his band of traitors house
baratheon owed its very existence to the
targaryens
was it not aegon the dragon himself who
elevated the bastard auris baratheon in
the war of conquest
and what of the starks the lannisters
the aarons of the vale all had been
spared and allowed to keep their lands
when aegon could easily have wiped them
out
centuries later the usurper and his
lackeys repaid aegon's benevolence
with treachery there are some who
dare to claim robert and his allies had
reason to rebel
they say the crown prince stole the
usurper's lady love
they say my father king aerys murdered
rickard stark and his son without just
cause whether these charges are true or
not
it doesn't matter the dragon answers to
no one
ares good name has been besmirched in
the years since the rebellion
he's been called a dangerous madman a
monster
a tyrant that brought his tragic end
upon himself
lies my father was a victim of
weaklings in his council lackwitz who
failed him in his hour of need
and let the rebellion spin out of
control
but it was not enough the royal army was
crushed at the battle of the trident
it was there the valiant rhaegar met
robert in single combat but the gods
betrayed
him and he perished by the usurper's
hand
as the field of fire had marked the end
of the andal centuries before
the battle of the trident seemed to
herald the end of the dragon kings
when word reached the capital of my
brother rhaegar's death
my father aerys moved to protect me as i
was the surviving heir to the throne
he sent me to the island fortress of
dragonstone along with my mother queen
rayla who was great with child
but as my father my king aerys targaryen
prepared to defend his throne to the
bitter end
little did he know of the horrors and
betrayals that awaited him and our
family